welcome back everybody and now look who
has joined me right here on the set look
what it is yeah yeah yeah here we go
Scary Spice America's Got Talent 41 year
old hot mama 3 who just recently and
looks fantastic I like that I want to
jump right into it
alright you Jerry Emma dropped the big
news it's gonna be a Spice Girls reunion
this seems to be a couple people missing
in there they're there in spirit but we
have like a few little surprises that
hopefully everyone will be excited about
like there's any like fighting inside
the Spice Girls that would be such a
buzzkill no I mean where we come from
girl power we're all about Co good go
power we started it as five and you know
as in spirit all five of us are always
gonna still be there well I have to say
that just you know in case there are
some spots that are available we have a
fantastic possible substitute who know I
love you and you know if one of the
girls is not coming I'm gonna be that
missing Spice Girls I'm gonna be sweetie
spice sweet and sparse
I Spit excited a of course you do and
she has the most high pitched voice
you've ever heard in your whole entire
life I love you to bits Heidi but maybe
next time America's Got Talent
number one show in the summer ten years
in a row yeah what do you like most
about it you like watching the talent
acts or at all your hot clothes or
assignment don't forget he created the
show yeah
ten ten years ago it was his first show
that he ever created so it's nice to
kind of have the original person as part
of the crew and I'm glad that I'm not
fired yet now I can't keep like talking
about all this without mentioning the
fact that you look amazing if you had to
give me three things that helps you the
most to get in the shape that you're in
what were those three things for sex sex
and more sex okay can we say that that's
great that's I think that's the kind
people want to hear I've got some
rapid-fire questions
oh my god all right get rid of it do you
still keep any of your old Spice Girl
costumes of course I do I have a whole
storage
favorite judge on a GT myself okay who'd
you rather double-date with are you
ready for this yeah Kim and Kanye Mariah
and her billionaire fiance James Packer
Taylor Swift and Tom Hiddleston I'd have
to go with tail tell us what I want to
know why she's she has changes her
boyfriend so much I want to live
vicariously would you ask her that like
go ahead I'm good so how did you do it
and why did you do it